j'ai mis le dossier people c'est la star
academy on va en parler parce que cette
semaine encore on l'a appris deux
anciens de people de la star academy ont
fait parler d'elles malheureusement en
mal il yad'abord oda le 13 octobre
dernier il ya eu un jugement de la cour
d'appel est bien qui a confirmé le fait
qu'elle soit condamnée à 18 mois de
prison pour abus de faiblesse sur un
couple d'octogénaires notamment des faux
chèques qui ont été faits et puis de son
côté yahoo sin qui va juger de 7
décembre prochain
notamment pour violences conjugales sur
son ex encore présomption d'innocence ça
sera le 7 juillet prochain
y en a qui ont cartonné après la star ac
en a qui sont complètement parti en
vrille on a fait un bilan on en parle
juste après regardez vous vous souvenez
d'autres dans l'astarac car elle
chantait ça
[Musique]
eh bien ça ne va pas mieux elle risque
13 mois de prison après avoir extorqué
30000 euros un couple de personnes âgées
en mauvaise posture aussi houcine il a
rendez-vous devant le tribunal de nancy
la semaine prochaine pour violences
conjugales
parmi les anciens de la star ac il ya
donc ceux qui se sont perdus il y a
aussi les stars jennifer la première a
cartonné en sortant du château
nolwenn 3 millions d'albums vendus en 15
ans de carrière son frein
m
sofia essaïdi la reine des comédies
musicales à la fiche aujourd'hui de
chicago est en route pour broadway
[Musique]
d'autres ont super bien géré aussi mais
loin des projecteurs exemple patxi et sa
célèbre crête quinze ans après la star
ac 3 il ne la portent plus mais il écrit
toujours des chansons jour 1 de luan et
ses 73 millions d' écoute c'est le jour
celui qu'on retient
enfin il y a ceux qui ont choisi des
chemins de traverse mais qui se font
plaisir
jean-pascal propriétaire d'un resto de
plage un saint-jean-de-luz ambiance
détente
mario qui a créé un magazine à dijon
développer un magazine qualitative sur
le destroy mis sur le vin son tourisme
pouvait être intéressant mais aussi
georges alain star ac 2 commentateurs de
sports extrêmes sur la musique de la
star ac ça ne s'invente pas dans les
trois communes fm et chauffage
certes sur les 147 candidats des neuf
saisons ils sont quand même une grosse
centaine à être complètement sortis des
radars alors en termes de bilan la star
ac' expériences positives ou négatives
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
myriam expériences négatives pour vous
bon doutait mais pourquoi non mais en
fait pour moi c'est c'est plutôt négatif
dans l'ensemble est ce qu'il y en a très
peu qui cartonne et qui font une vraie
carrière derrière et ce qu'on oublie de
dire c'est que sur la les 150 candidats
qui ont participé à cette émission
la plupart sont ressortis avec des
dépressions ils ont mal géré leur argent
enfin il y en a tout un tas n'y a pas
que houcine et ode à qui on voit la
cohue des problèmes qui ont des
problèmes et je trouve que le suivi
après ce genre d'émission est souvent
mauvais et souvent la chute est assez
violent pour eux donc pour moi c'est
négatif très bien au guillaume pourquoi
positif non non non pardon je vais t'en
as oui mais si je suis pas du tout
d'accord
il y en a combien qui rêve de voir le
soleil ils ont au moins vu le soleil si
cette expérience-là proportionnellement
il ya neuf saisons il ya 15 entre 15 et
18 élèves par saison ça fait 150 élèves
d'une poignée qui ripe tamisée globale
s'ils ont manié de mal mais ça s'annonce
mal suivi n'ont pas si je fais le pari
en bois à thaon pas tous en même temps
mais va le trouble que va nous dire
exactement sur grosso modo 150 candidats
et oui il y en a 10 % dont on parle
c'est pas le ratio normal dans ce qu'ils
vont faire une carrière d'un an
et alors dû divine évidemment je suis
pas d'accord avec ce que dit myriam
totalement d'accord avec guillaume on
n'a pas parlé d' elodie frégé par
exemple dans le sujet que juste
formidable on n'a pas parlé de lettres
d'exception qui a été les lego riz le
manège aérien la scène de marshall a été
génial quentin mosimann fait une grande
carrière en pâtit ok alors je dois
galles par la matu à quatre couleurs et
tous mais effectivement la question
qu'on se pose aussi c'est malgré tout
voilà comment est ce qu'on passe de 2 de
la lumière comme ça à londres
psychologiquement c'est forcément c'est
difficile catherine rambert justement
voilà la star academy a eu dix saisons
est-ce que c'est pas comme des mômes
qu'on met trop rapidement dans la
lumière
ensuite la presse people ou bof miren
fait pas les malins l'a traitée peut
ensuite fait ses choux gras dessus des
expos les 6e manière trop violente comme
aussi de presse en ligne est vrai que
c'est vrai que c'est un passage de
l'autre côté du miroir comme alice au
pays des merveilles après sa brutale
retour et à la réalité
les chaînes prétendent qu'ils aient un
suivi psychologique est quasiment
inexistant et myriam a raison de le
préciser il ya beaucoup dépression
nerveuse et puis c'est pas les seuls à
rappelez-vous guiseppe le très bel homme
très intelligent vous savez de qui veut
épouser mon fils voilà où il a fait de
la prison aussi loi n'a concerné qu'un
jour il va mettre des hauts et des bas
terrible et puis il y avait un truc un
cas dramatique c'est françois-xavier et
félix de l'ex rivale qui s'est suicidé
donc c'est quand même même si c'est une
belle exposition on est d'accord il ya
quand même un retour de bâton qui peut
être assez dangereux et très
déstabilisant je dis pas que c'est que
c'est forcément parce qu'on a besoin de
personnages tragiques pour faire ses
missions et on espère et ce qui est vrai
en tout cas c'est que c'est que malgré
tout deux faces et la lumière c'est ça
rend très fragile aussi ce à quoi qu'il
arrive mais gaouaoui mathieu moi à
l'époque je travaille en maison disque
j'ai fait 10 en 2010 et j'écris suite à
ça un livre ça plaît je me souviens d
oublier où je parlais de tous les gens
qui avaient oublié ce dont on parle
c'est pas du tout propre à la star ac'
merci aux personnes exposées au public à
la notoriété
c'était le cas avant l'existence de
l'astarac ya plein de d'artistes ont mal
vécu leur descente aux enfers pendant
des décennies et la star ac c'était
quand même la remise est une question
d'âme qui demandent plus compliqué à
gérer que vous avez 18 mai oui non mais
ils n'ont rien demandé on vient les
chercher chez eux
j'ai demandé à participer à une émission
sur la plus grande chaîne de france
parrainée par la plus grande maison de
disque du monde donc il ya un moment si
la demande et on vous dit n'importe mais
ensuite on pourra avancer tous les gens
leur dire écoute nous suit nous ce sont
les meilleurs tu viendras de grandes
mais tous les gens donnent pas démarré
leur carrière commence à 18 ans on
démarre rarement sa carrière à 57 kg a
battu avec moi mes présentations des
pardons présomption d'innocence au pied
très bien mais est ce que vous pensez
réellement que ses actes parce que ce
gars houcine a fait la star academy a
peut-être quinze ans qu'aujourd'hui il a
le droit de de violenter sa femme en
fait mon ami ça fait maintenant ici
parce que on déballe salariat violenté
son sa femme et qui va passer en procès
à cause de ça et on dit est ce que c'est
lié à cette a7 à cet effet télé réalité
qu'il a tourné à 15 ans en arrière pour
moi non ce n'est pas lié cette télé
réalité quand on est quand y'a quelque
chose quand on a quelque chose de
malsain dans la tête on l'a avec ou sans
télé il est sûr c'est que la célébrité
quand vous êtes jeunes ou quoi c'est une
loupe malgré tout surtout s'il ya un
problème ça va le grossir donc c'est
tout ce qu'on dira mais loana l'a dit
l'autre jour elle a dit que je que je
fais que ce que j'ai fait le loft ou pas
j'aurais vriet de gagner parce que j'ai
ma vie rieuse à l'intérieur
si vous êtes bien placé pour le savoir
aussi vous êtes connu depuis longtemps
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
violent la célébrité sera forcément que
du du sourire tout le temps c'est vrai
que j'ai pas connu nombre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça peut arriver j'imagine j'imagine
raconter des choses c'est de permettre
largué j'ai eu des témoignages je pense
part de mathieu ces paliers
véritablement au programme les boys band
dans les boys band take ouvriers aussi
tous ceux des petites chanteuses les
mélodies et tout à l'époque les
chanteuses qu'on connut très tôt
effectivement la célèbre la célébrité
quel que soit alpha on n'a pas besoin de
sortir d'un programme type comme celui
ci une fois que pour passe à londres
quel que soit l'âge également c'est
compliqué là longtemps mais pour
terminer la seule question c'est est
effectivement on annonce partout son cas
money to pretend et molle pardon pendant
tout le temps ils sont très suivis très
suivi écouté benoît de la star est que
je connais bien m'a dit le psy on la
croisait une fois il tape sur la main
dit ça va approuver
c'est vraiment voilà bien placé pour le
savoir
on est d'accord je veux dire c'est une
évidence ont laissé la démence qui s'en
foutent un peu ma mairie considère que
c'est pas leur travail en fait une
baisse et les chants vote soit disant
attention ils considèrent que c'est pas
leur travail c'est à dire
il met des gens à l'antenne et derrière
effectivement entre chaque tournage
effectivement ils sont pas du tout suivi
ça il n'y a pas de débat la thur bon
très bien vous ferez votre avis chez
vous en tout cas d'heure on a un sondage
là-dessus justement qui va s'afficher
maintenant voilà 17 ans pas la fin de la
star ac
que retenez-vous à un vivier de talents
ou oui c'est quand même malgré tout
voilà malgré tout parce qu'évidemment là
on a parlé un qui arrive pas à leurs
dents lui évidemment on aurait pu parler
elodie qui cartonne de nolwenn de
jennifer de grégory marshall est vendu
beaucoup de disques en termes mosimann
habituellement il y en a d'autres et
tout ça on a fait le tour sur ce sujet
les amis oui jouer juste te dire
mireille mathieu la fin c'est le jeu de
l'achat des 60 chirac c'est la star ac
de l'époque lé bon la lan
pénible
[Applaudissements]